[موسيقى] أجنبية
[تصفيق]
من أكثر المجالات التي تثير قلقي ،
زيادة القدرة العامة
لهذه النماذج على التلاعب لإقناعها
بتقديم نوع من الفردي ، وأعتقد أن
هذا مجال مهم مثير للقلق ،
وأعتقد أن هناك  هناك الكثير من
السياسات التي يمكن للشركات أن
تتبناها طواعية ويسعدني أن أتحدث عما
نفعله هناك
وأعتقد أن بعض اللوائح التنظيمية ستكون
حكيمة جدًا في هذا الموضوع ،
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى]
هذه الأنظمة لديها القدرة على
التأثير فيها  واضح
وبطرق دقيقة للغاية وأعتقد أن هذا
مهم بشكل خاص لسلامة
الأطفال ولكن هذا سيؤثر
علينا جميعًا أحد الأشياء التي
سنقوم بها بأنفسنا التنظيم أو لا ولكن
أعتقد أن النهج التنظيمي سيكون
مفيدًا أيضًا  هي متطلبات حول كيفية
تعيين قيم هذه الأنظمة وكيفية
استجابة هذه الأنظمة للأسئلة
التي يمكن أن تسبب تأثيرًا ، لذلك نود أن
نتشارك معك لا يمكننا الاتفاق أكثر على
أهمية
[موسيقى]